baked goods for cancer research baked
goods for cancer research it's a great
cause baked goods for breast cancer
research it's a great cause Brenda
people don't only die from breast cancer
all cancers matter okay it's for my aunt
yeah I just need to buff out this spot
we got to paint the whole car paint the
whole car it's only one spot if we paint
one part of the car we got to paint the
whole car it all matters no this one's
dying I'm gonna give it a little bit
more water we give each plant an equal
amount of water see I get that it's just
that this plants been in the shade and
because of where it was placed thinking
that there's a little bit more water I'm
sorry are you saying because this one's
been in the shade it deserves be on top
of all the other plans is that what
you're saying no no um I'm just gonna
give it a little bit more water um I
feel like the right side is shorter than
the left and I'd like them to match
equally ooh if I cut one side I
definitely have to cut the other side
wait wait I don't need to love said cut
I just want them to be at equal length
I definitely cut them both equal last
time so maybe one of your sides just
goes faster than the other let's get
started
I'm just gonna give it more water
because racism